if you're struggling with your business
if you feel that you deserve better if
you thought you'd be further along with
your company than where you are right
now then you're going to love this
channel hi I'm Evan Carmichael and I
believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and on this channel I share
my entrepreneurial advice how I went
from making three hundred dollars a
month and not having enough to survive
to build in a business that had
respectable brand name companies in over
30 countries and eventually being
acquired I share how helped
entrepreneurs raise half a million to 15
million dollars to grow their company
and I share how I built one of the most
successful entrepreneur websites in the
world I'll share stories of families
entrepreneurs and how they got started
people like Bill Gates and Oprah Winfrey
and Donald Trump and not how they make
an extra million dollars now but how do
they get started how did it go from that
idea to their first million dollars and
how can you do the same thing and I
answer your questions I give guidance
advice inspiration to help you along
your journey and answer the specific
questions that you have you're
struggling with right now I want to help
you become the best entrepreneur that
you can be and I hope to hear from you
soon enjoy the channel
you